(bright upbeat music)
- [Malcolm] Here in this part of Chicago
a lot of folks list this neighborhood
as a food desert.
A lot of places that
got abandoned buildings
but not a place that do
a lot of healthy food
in the neighborhood.
I want to take the
opportunity to go around,
show people how to farm,
show 'em that this type
of work is healing.
- [Narrator] This Great
Big Story was made possible
by Horizon Organic.
(bright upbeat music)
- My name is Malcolm Evans.
I am the farm manager here
at Urban Growers Collective.
The farm we own now is
the South Chicago farm
and this our main farm here.
We grow all different type a vegetables:
spinach, spring onions, arugula,
lettuce mix, collard greens,
different type of varieties of radishes.
After we harvest it we put it on the bus
for Fresh Move.
- Fresh Move's mobile market
is literally a market that moves.
It's a Chicago Transit authority bus
that got transformed into a place
where people can come on board.
Instead of going to the destination,
can purchase healthy food.
Our focus for Fresh
Moves geographically is
the South Side and the
West Side of Chicago.
These neighborhoods have historically
not had healthy food access.
- This one, give it about one more day,
it's ready to go, like
put it on your windowsill.
- We harvest and sell probably
two tons of food every week.
We're able to bring the freshest,
highest quality affordable produce.
We have really consistent folks
who come and shop and people love it.
They joke when their
favorite thing is not there.
And, you know, come back and expect
to see it next week;
and it's a pretty joyful
exchange between everybody
and definitely like keeps
us motivated to know
that the work that we're doing makes such
a big difference.
- [Malcolm] I definitely see more folks
when I'm doing a Fresh Move
programs coming on the bus
learning about vegetables
and me talking about how
healthy this piece is for them.
Coming here, seeing this stuff grow
that I put in the ground,
I feel like when I do the work that I do,
I accomplish something.
It make me feel like, yeah,
these people is paying attention.
They see that this food is life.
(bright upbeat music)